it's the kind of situation that demands
a swift and uncompromising response a
hostage is taken
bombs are planted a biochemical weapon
is located the five defenders prepare
for the coming storm these operators
have gadgets weapons and abilities
designed for this very purpose they
erect barricades and reinforced walls to
limit options for the attackers Mira can
put a bulletproof window in these
armored walls information is key while
the defenders have access to a set of
default cameras Valkyries black-eye
cameras hidden in creative locations
provide the edge her team needs not all
attackers will be watching the objective
note some like Cappy etta lurk silently
in the side rooms and hallways of the
building eager to pick off unaware
attackers with the defense's and
firepower arrayed against them this
won't be a simple operation it's a
veritable siege but the attackers have
tricks of their own and their own skills
are uniquely suited to the task a
regular wall is no obstacle for Ashe a
reinforced one is no deterrent to
thermite
and what's worse during a tense standoff
than a phone call from Korea knackered
Oh pity there's no respawning during the
round every sound is occluded every
sheet of drywall is a new potential
angle of attack and when the chips are
down and the barricades are crumbling it
will be communication and teamwork that
win the day even if the final moments
are between two operators in desparate
complex this is the story of Rainbow six
siege
Rainbow six began life as a written work
by Tom Clancy a best-selling author
known for his popular military thrillers
what interests you about the military
landscape today today well same thing
that's they've still got nicest toys and
they're still instruments of national
policy when the president picks up the
phone and says we have to do something
today there the people have to go do it
after publishing his first novel The
Hunt for Red October in 1984 clancy
would go on to write a number of books
over the next seven years which would be
turned into films including patriot
games clear and present danger and the
sum of all fears but his 1998 novel
Rainbow six didn't go that route the
novel feature recurring character John
Clarke in charge of team rainbow Joe
John's running a group called rainbow
it's a NATO multinational counter-terror
team and that's sort of a job for John
while the book has yet to make the leap
to the silver screen it was turned into
a video game by Clancy's own Red Storm
entertainment and in 1998 the original
Rainbow six was released for PC and
later ported to n64 and PlayStation by
comparison to other contemporary
shooters at that time Rainbow six nearly
rated as a simulation and emphasized
planning and tactics but as sequels were
eventually released each slept a little
further away from the original premise
French software company Ubisoft
purchased Red Storm in August 2000 and
began releasing other franchises under
the
klancy name like splinter cell and ghost
recall but by 2008 and the release of
Rainbow Six Vegas to Rainbow six his
original identity had dramatically
changed bishop it's been a while d it
has you look different the next game in
the series was to be Rainbow six
Patriots which was revealed in 2011 the
game was powered by Ubisoft proprietary
anvil engine which had been used for
games like Assassin's Creed 2 it was
also set to deal with the new type of
antagonist in the form of a domestic
terrorist organization called the true
Patriots while it was set to feature a
multiplayer mode the game would be
focused around a narrative driven
single-player experience but the game
never launched between leadership
changes an aging game engine and the
looming release of next-generation
consoles Patriots was scrapped and
development on Rainbow six siege
officially kicked off in 2013 leaving
behind the challenging domestic
terrorism narrative of Patriots the game
went back to its roots Rainbow was
reactivated to deal with a global
terrorist threat called white masks this
organization has the ability to carry
out
but unlike Patriots siege was designed
primarily as a multiplayer only game and
that was abundantly clear when the game
was revealed at e3 2014 okay I say we
brush no I'd rather not
I mean they always defend it with a
shitload of booby traps I say we drop on
the roof and breach the three
second-floor windows we don't come in at
once
what do you guys think okay yeah that
sounds gonna transport for a helicopter
drop arrive in some ways the multiplayer
only nature of the game was a gamble on
the one hand the Rainbow six series name
wasn't exactly in the forefront of
everyone's minds at this time so
attracting new players was a priority
but a multiplayer only game could
potentially alienate the fans who had
enjoyed Vegas - and wanted a robust
single-player experience during
development the team at Ubisoft Montreal
had focused on three main elements for
the game teamwork
tactics and tension right set up on
three one two three
good job guys yeah one ingredient that
went into creating that tension was
destructible environments the idea that
new angles of attack could come out of
nowhere and that cunning players could
reshape the conflict to their advantage
so hey Mona Liberty resistant visionary
on touch' the resolution offensive the
tuna fact the tone and intact de la
fortuna back to Germany but this also
played into the tactical angle the idea
that a well-planned assault could carry
a today
offense ISA received a patent Momoko
Jenner a Lisa usual six prima Nala XP my
son Austin syntactic real of fresh lava
lava como la very avocado brush
civically decedent on deliver to duty
duty liberty era to officials were able
to make the addition of operators
brought a new touch to the series
admittedly even the first Rainbow six
had you choose different team members to
bring on a mission but operators in
siege were different
more like distinct classes with their
own weapons and special abilities in
siege each member of your squad has a
distinct set of skills and the gang
change in special ability and like most
modern class based shooters the
operators were designed to be distinct
both from a gameplay perspective but
also visually a tougher feat in a
setting where tactical equipment is a
must
I know what you wondering what's in the
canister I could tell you
but they're not ethnic Pieta the game
would enter a closed beta in September
2015
but server issues marred some players
impressions of it and when the first
Rainbow six game in seven years finally
released in December 2015 the core
gameplay was mostly well received
Rainbow six siege may not be the rainbow
game fans remember but it lays a solid
foundation for the future matches are
full of constant tension and meaningful
kills on the one hand the
moment-to-moment gameplay experience is
fantastic every second of the short
rounds matter Rainbow six siege is a
house of cards intricate impressive and
incredibly fragile if the gameplay was
intriguing to reviewers the amount
available at release was less so the
game launched with 10 maps and 20
operators but several critics noted that
the initial offering felt thin for the
full box retail price my time with siege
lose me feeling like this Rainbow six
revival is a skeleton with not a lot of
meat on its bones it's not worth it and
it's not really a river 6 game it just
doesn't it's nothing like the Rainbow
six games that made the name Rainbow six
still it was a foundation that the
company planned to build on an ubisoft
montreal committed to an aggressive
patch release schedule to support their
new game the game launches on December
1st and for the Rainbow six siege team
and players this is only the beginning
the game will continue to evolve with
new content throughout the year while
critics had spoken the players would be
the ultimate arbiter of whether the game
would be a long-term success just a day
after its release it became clear that
few people were taking part in the
latest world to bear the Tom Clancy name
the stats for the PC version the game on
Steam showed that there were few people
playing even if a majority of players
bought the game through you play
determined to attract players to the
game Ubisoft opened a free-to-play
weekend just weeks after US release a
move that many saw as an admission of
trouble the games post-launch players
who owned the game were dealing with
issues of their own including problems
with hackers and lag by August 2016
Ubisoft had released three major content
patches for the game operations black
ice dust lime and skull rain I'm coming
for you
they had implemented their anti cheat
system battle AI and while developers
have often been hesitant to speak about
player numbers except an easily digested
and positive sound bytes
Ubisoft revealed during skull rain that
the player base was higher than it had
been at launch there was a dip after the
patch stabilized but siege was slowly
but steadily making a comeback on the
eSports side of things the game had
launched with a perennial issue for many
titles which platform is the official
one at launch the eSports program
organized by ESL supported both PC and
Xbox one some players from previous
games like furious G even made the swap
to siege from Vegas the adults of all
new innova did you confess to us only
guess there is some is just a few just
yeah the round-robin format League would
see teams like Penta ynk and continuum
become Finals champions for PC in the
first year excellence gaming became the
first and last ever Pro League champions
for Xbox one as the platform was moved
to a separate major league or than any
of the results though the early Pro
League showed that the game had eSports
potential with incredible and exciting
moments it also had an itch it had the
one life
high tension gameplay of counter-strike
the ability interactions of many
class-based games and the addition of
dynamic destruction
at the first six Invitational at the end
of the year North America would take
home the first ever trophy at the event
but as the game continued its growth
throughout 2017 so too did its East
Horse viewership and as the game
continued to add new operators the
interactions between attack and defense
continued to grow Ike you can now see
defenders who are using their cameras
this is incredible
so like you can see electrical devices
20 meters away and now she can see
people using the cameras on a defensive
team with the game's continued rise a
community arose with it and while they
loved to discuss the games tactics and
intricacies so what this means is that
your team should have rumors on the
overall any operator can roam but the
best ones are definitely the ones of
three speed and one armor they also
loved means it's alright it's alright to
chunka is here to save us
I don't know if I'd even consider I
guess my videos expectations first of
all you're probably considering being
videos but I would follow those with
sketches as opposed to means but enough
to cut through nearly any barrier known
to man
[Music]
[Applause]
the thing people just like to see the
seriousness of siege mixed in with
comedy real life and real needs I know
what you're wondering
what's in the canister for King laser
sights no the game's content roll out
took a momentary backseat with the
release of Operation Health in June 2017
operation health is basically a three
months period of time that we're going
to be taking in order to fixing and
repairing the game as well as investing
in car technologies and and online text
to make sure that the game is as
long-lasting as possible maybe one of
the most maligned periods in the games
post release history operation health
was supposed to bring fixes to the
game's engine which had some issues with
lag hit detection and matchmaking since
launch but the patch got its own
assortment of memes too and then when it
was like one week left until blood
orchid and I went through their
checklist and they don't fix like one or
two things that have the taunts of stuff
they mentioned that like this was a meme
this was three months of the exact same
thing with no changes hopefully oh my
god what am I am I'm the bottom of the
bat for you he was authorized to came
out and they talked about how they were
just trying to lay the foundation they
were going to fix more things in the
future which they eventually did I'll
get credit for that they fixed a lot of
problems that were with the game once
back into a more normal schedule of
content releases the game has continued
its growth with every new operator new
interactions enter the game and the
strategy deepens for me most the most
appeal that I have game operators is how
do you say gadget on their own just like
alibi is coming out and she has
Holograms okay how can I set this up the
trick people at work my position to all
games were filled like turn corner and
the reaction will just be to shoot
instead of droning it out or like check
and see if attack she is a hologram the
second six Invitational held in February
2018 saltpeter
viewership of over 300,000 while numbers
for concurrent players on Steam are only
a small slice of the pie Marsh saw the
game cracked the top 5 with a new
all-time high of 176 thousand players
and in May 2018 the game was the 11th
highest watch on Twitch up from 21st a
year prior and even though big
tournaments helped there is some
evidence to suggest that the game is
still steadily growing the game crossed
the 30 million player threshold in April
2018 in June at e3 Ubisoft announced the
game had hit the 35 million player work
the subreddit subscriber base for the
game is closing in on more established
games like dota 2 and major
organizations like fnatic faze clan Team
Liquid and cloud nine have picked up
rosters for pro league while Ubisoft has
announced a revenue sharing initiative
that splits profits from teen themed
in-game items at the six Invitational
Ubisoft Montreal announced that the game
would not have a sequel but instead look
to a 10-year lifespan
[Music]
whether or not the game makes it there a
commitment like that would have been
unbelievable in December 2015
every game wants to be the next big
thing worse they want it to be that at
launch but unlike the massive successes
and instant flops of recent years an
unlikely Ubisoft game has steadily built
up a fanbase they did it by reinventing
what the franchise meant while
simultaneously committing to a post
release support structure that would
keep the game relevant for years to come
in the process they built not only a
devoted player base but a growing
eSports scene as well but siege like its
players so often do define some heavy
odds to make it this
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button